Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am
going to explain a drama film called
“Room”. Watch out and take care!
Twenty-four-year-old Joy lives in a tiny room
with her son Jack. The room has a toilet and
bath in one corner and a makeshift kitchen in
the other. The mother and son share a single bed
because of the limited space. It has only a
skylight that works as the window and the door
needs a passcode to be opened. Jack has never in
his life been out of the room. His mother Joy was
abducted by a man seven years ago who has been
holding her captive in the same room ever since.
Jack is the result of the sexual abuse Joy had
to go through because of the abductor. The only
form of entertainment the kid has is an old
TV which he thinks is a magic box. He believes
that people inside the TV are aliens who live
on another planet with trees and animals.
The film begins with Jack waking up and saying
hi to the inanimate objects around the room
like the chair, the wardrobe, the sink, and so
on. Since he has only seen two people in his life,
he has made friends with the objects around
the room. The kid has no concept of space and
thinks that the room is all that exists. To avoid
explaining the harsh truth of his life, Joy has
never told him about the outside world. The two
have named the abductor, “Old Nick”. He comes to
Joy every night and assaults her sexually. After
seven years of torture, she has gotten used to it.
He also brings them necessary groceries
and buys them clothes once in a while.
Jack is excited because today is his fifth
birthday. His mother makes him a cake with
whatever materials they have. Jack is stoked about
getting something he has only ever seen on TV
but is disappointed to see the cake has no
candles. He demands that Joy should have asked
Old Nick for candles for their Sunday treat. Joy
claims she can only ask him for necessary goods.
When it turns dark, she makes Jack sleep
inside a tiny cupboard as usual. She does
this so the kid wouldn’t have to witness Old Nick
assaulting her. When the abductor enters the room,
Jack watches him through the slats of the
cupboard. He is terrified of going out
because he can tell the man hurts his mother.
The following day, as Joy is eating breakfast, a
bad tooth falls off her mouth. She hands it to her
son who keeps it in his mouth. They have breakfast
which is only a piece of toast. The kid wishes
to eat something else but Joy doesn’t respond,
knowing that this is all she can provide
him. When Jack wakes up the next morning,
he is overjoyed to see a brand new toy car on
the table. Old Nick has brought it for him as a
present for his birthday. Jack believes that
Old Nick is a magician who can bring stuff
out of the TV. He plays with the car the entire
day around the room. For an hour or so, the two
scream at the ceiling, hoping to catch someone’s
attention, but as usual, nothing happens.
Later while talking, Jack mentions his imaginary
pet dog Lucky. Joy tells him that Lucky isn’t
real, making him upset. When Joy is distracted,
Jack sees a mouse on the floor for the first
time in his life. He tries to touch it but Joy
notices and chases it away. He is sad because
the mouse was the only animal he has ever seen.
That night, while making dinner, Joy accidentally
leaves the toaster oven on and it catches
on fire. She quickly turns it off and tries
to wave off the smell, hoping Old Nick wouldn’t
notice. However, when he comes around at night,
he smells the burnt cheese instantly. He gets
annoyed and calls her names. When she snaps back
with a snarky comment, he gets violently angry
and almost hits her. It turns out that he was
laid off from work six months ago, and can hardly
provide for the three of them. Poor Jack tries to
ignore the conversation but accidentally makes
a noise. Old Nick notices and tries to open the
cupboard to see him. To keep him from talking
to her son, Joy invites him to the bed.
Later that night, Jack sneaks out of his cupboard
and tiptoes over to the two of them. Old Nick
happens to be awake and sees the kid. He lunges
for Jack but Joy throws herself on top of him,
preventing him from touching her son. An enraged
Nick threatens to kill her and storms off leaving
a crying Jack behind. Joy consoles him as he
sobs in her arms and apologizes for coming out
of the cupboard. The next morning, the room
is suspiciously cold. Joy notices that their
heater is turned off which means Old Nick must
have cut off the power supply to the shed.
Joy knows that they cannot survive in the cold
for long. Moreover, with the shortage of money,
she is afraid Nick will starve them to death. So,
she sits Jack down and explains to him that they
are being held in a shed by a bad person.
She tells him that she was only seventeen
when Old Nick asked her to help him with his sick
dog. He fooled her and kidnapped her in the shed.
Before that, she used to live with Jack’s
grandparents in a house that had a hammock.
The kid refuses to believe her and declares that
trees, houses, and hammocks only exist on TV.
Although Jack is stubborn, Joy keeps on
telling him things about the outside world.
She even shows him a dried leaf that has fallen
on the skylight but the kid insists the leaves
are green so she must be lying.
The next day, while watching TV,
he asks her if trees and people are really
real. Joy calmly explains to him how the
real world works, finally making him
believe her. Not wasting much time,
she devises a plan to escape. She boils water and
uses it to make it look like Jack has a fever.
She even forces herself to vomit and spreads
it around the pillow to make him smell bad.
The kid cries and claims he doesn’t want to
do it. Joy doesn’t enjoy seeing him crying
but she has no other way to escape. When Old Nick
arrives that night, she tells him that the cold
has made Jack sick. Nick touches his forehead
which is burning because of the hot water.
He claims that he will bring antibiotics the next
day and leaves. Joy is disappointed because she
had thought he would take Jack to the hospital
where the kid would have a chance to escape. The
following day, she thinks of a new plan. She
asks Jack to pretend to be dead and rolls him
in a rug. She trains him to unroll himself and run
for help. The kid is told he will be taken outside
by Old Nick where he will meet real people who
he has to ask for help. He is scared but agrees
to do it. When Old Nick arrives a while later,
Joy has already wrapped up Jack inside the rug
and is pretending to cry. She claims that he
died during the night and blames Old Nick for
his death. Nick panics and quickly brings the kid
out, still rolled up in the rug. He puts him into
the back of a pickup truck and drives off. From
inside the rug, Jack feels the truck driving.
He unravels from the rug and is mesmerized to see
the full view of the sky for the first time. When
the truck slows down, he carefully jumps out
of it. Old Nick notices and stops the truck
but by then, Jack has already met a man walking
his dog. Old Nick tries to bring Jack back to
the vehicle but the man finds it suspicious and
threatens to call the police. Old Nick drives away
after leaving the kid lying on the ground.
Jack stays there until he is rescued by the
police. He tells them about his mother
and shows them the tooth he has of her.
When he mentions that they live in a shed that
they aren’t allowed to leave, the police realize
the severity of the situation. They quickly call
for backup and start searching for the shed.
Only some hours later, they rescue Joy who
is fortunately safe. She reunites with her
son and praises him for his work. The two hug,
celebrating their freedom after being captured
for seven years. When Jack wakes up the next day,
he finds himself in a bed in a hospital room. He
looks outside the window, still unable to believe
that the outside world is real. Joy and he takes
a bath in a shower for the first time. Jack is
scared to go under running water but eventually
gets used to it. The doctors perform several
tests on them and declare them healthy. They
are suggested to wear a lot of sunscreens since
they were hardly exposed to sunlight in captivity.
Jack is also told to wear sunglasses if the world
seems too bright. The kid is nervous to talk to
the doctor so he quietly whispers to Joy if he
wants to say something. Joy’s parents Nancy and
Robert finally arrive at the hospital and embrace
their long-lost daughter in a tight hug. They had
accepted she was never going to return after
suddenly disappearing one day. Joy is told that
her parents have divorced and her mother is now
dating a man named Leo. Following that, Joy and
Jack are taken home where a crowd of people and
reporters have gathered to witness the return.
Jack needs help to walk down the stairs because he
is not used to it. He meets Leo who is delighted
to see both of them. After they are settled, Nancy
comments that they should cut Jack’s hair but the
kid quietly whispers that his strength is in his
hair. At dinner, the family enjoys a nutritious
meal that is foreign for Jack. He eats ice cream
for the first time and experiences a brain freeze.
Joy notices that her father hasn’t talked to Jack
at all. She realizes that he is not comfortable
with Jack being his grandchild because he was
the product of her being sexually assaulted.
Enraged that he is not willing to accept
her son, she gets into an argument with him
and storms off to her room with Jack.
The next day, Joy shows Jack a picture
of her and her high school friends. She is
clearly annoyed at the fact that their lives
turned out to be nice when she was rotting
in the hell of a room. Jack has a hard time
adjusting to the new life. He never leaves his
mother's side and doesn’t talk to anyone else.
Leo makes the kid comfortable and talks to him
like a father which helps him a lot. Joy falls
deep into depression after failing to be
happy even after getting out of captivity.
She forces Jack to play even when he refuses
to and gets into a huge argument with her
mother. Some days later, their family's lawyer
informs them that they will need money for the
upcoming trial, and the easiest way to get
some is to do a prime-time interview.
A journalist shows up at the house to interview
Joy. She asks her intrusive questions about
self-harm and her relationship with the captor,
making her feel worse than she already did.
At one point in the interview, Joy is asked why
she didn’t beg the abductor to leave Jack in an
orphanage, implying that she was selfish. The
interview has upset her so much that she sinks
into depression. The next morning Jack walks to
the bathroom and is horrified to see his mother
laying on the ground. Joy has attempted to commit
suicide but she is soon saved by the paramedics.
While Joy is admitted to the hospital, Jack
is left alone with Nancy and Leo. With time,
he begins opening up to them and gets used
to being around people. Leo brings his dog
home which excites Jack, who still remembers
his imaginary dog, Lucky. One day, Jack tells
Nancy he wants to cut his hair and send it to Joy
because she needs his strength more than he does.
Nancy happily does as he says and gives the boy
a neat haircut. At the end of it, the kid tells
her that he loves her. Nancy is overwhelmed and
hardly manages to whisper back I love you.
That day, a neighbor's kid calls Jack out to play.
He makes a friend for the first time in his life
and plays with him in the backyard. At the same
time, Joy returns home and smiles while watching
him play. When the mother and the son meet, she
claims that his hair helped her get well quickly.
As time passes, Jack experiences several things
with his mother. They go to different restaurants,
parks, and places that they didn’t get to visit
for all those years. They also hang a hammock
at the house that Jack had always wanted
to play in. As the two are swinging in it,
Jack asks to visit the room once. Joy is shocked
at the request but she agrees to take him for a
visit. When Jack returns to the place, he comments
if it has shrunk since they were last here because
he remembers it being bigger. Before leaving, he
wishes the objects in the room a goodbye like he
used to wish them while in captivity.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to help
the channel out. Thank You for watching.